dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with carriage or knife ahead
this work is about 3d printing flexible
molds for objects with detail geometry
the main observation is that the final
object not only has to be cast that also
has to be removed conveniently from the
mold finding an appropriate layout for
the cuts is a non-trivial problem the
technique and evers to have the least
amount of cuts and the length of the
cuts is also subject to minimization I
see the light bulb lighting up in the
heads of our season fellow scholars
immediately noticing that this sounds
like an optimization problem and in this
problem we start out from advanced cut
layout and iteratively remove as many of
these cuts as possible until some
prescribed threshold is met
however we have to be vigilant about the
fact that these cuts will result in the
formation during the removal process we
mentioned before that we are interested
in shapes that have geometry that is
rich in details
therefore this distortion effect is to
be minimized aggressively also we cannot
remove these cuts indefinitely because
sometimes more cats have to be added to
reduce the stress induced by the removal
process this is a cunning plan however a
plan that only works if we can predict
where and how these defamations will
happen therefore we have to simulate
this process on our computer during
removal forces are applied to the mold
which we also have to take into
consideration to this end there is an
actual simulation of the entirety of the
extraction process to make sure that the
material can be removed from the mold in
a non destructive manner
wow the paper discusses tons of issues
that arise from this problem formulation
for instance what one should do with the
tiny air bubbles stock interested or the
optimization part is also non trivial to
which a highly effective homebrew
solution is presented and there's a lot
more make sure to have a look of course
as always we would love to hear your
ideas about possible applications of
this technique
leave your thoughts in the comment
section
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]